THROUGHOUT THE CITY AS WE ALL
TRY TO GET THROUGH THIS
TOGETHER.
WE WANT YES WE DO.
HERE NOW WITH REACTION,
UNITED STATES LABORED APARTMENT
SECRETARY EUGENE SCALIA.
YOU KNOW THAT JOBLESS CLAIMS
BETTER THAN ANYBODY, MAYBE
BEFORE WE GET TO ASKING THESE
VIEWERS, GET YOUR INITIAL
THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW YOU SEE
THINGS TODAY.
>> TODAY AS WE JUST HEARD IT, WE
REPORTED THAT 700,000 JOBS WERE
LOST IN THE MONTH OF MARCH.
AND 6.6 MILLION AMERICANS HAD
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT WHICH IS
A VERY LARGE NUMBER OBVIOUSLY.
THERE IS A LOT OF FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP AT THIS MOMENT AS WE
TAKE THE MEASURES THAT WE NEED
TO TO DEFEAT THE VIRUS.
IT’S A DIFFICULT PERIOD FOR MANY
AMERICANS.
I THINK THE GOOD NEWS IS IT HAS
BEEN ANTICIPATED, IN A SENSE
IT’S BEEN PURPOSEFUL.
THE PRESIDENT AND CONGRESS HAVE
MOVED QUICKLY TO PROVIDE RELIEF.
>> Dana: I HAD THAT PACKAGE
THEY ARE FROM BRIAN, AND HE
TALKED ABOUT THE DOG WALKER, OR
SITTING BUSINESS.
FIRST QUESTION WE GOT FROM
VIEWERS IS I THINK ONE THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE ON THEIR
MINDS AND IT’S SOMETHING THAT
SECRETARY MNUCHIN DID TALK ABOUT
YESTERDAY, WHICH IS THIS.
AS AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IS
THERE ANY’S DON’T MAKE ANYTHING
SPECIFIC THAT THEY SHOULD DO IF
THEY ALSO BECOME UNEMPLOYED?
>> WELL, THERE ARE A FEW WAYS
THAT THEY CAN LOOK FOR RELIEF.
FIRST OF ALL SECRETARY MNUCHIN
PROBABLY MENTIONED, ONE REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE CARES ACT,
WHICH THE PRESIDENT SIGNED LAST
WEEK, IS THE PROVISION MAKING
PAYMENTS BY THE IRS TO MOST
AMERICANS.
IT WILL BE A $1500 PAYMENT FOR
DEPENDENT CHILDREN AND WILL BE
ANOTHER $500.
SO THAT IS FINANCIAL RELIEF THAT
IS ON THE WAY TO MOST AMERICANS.
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS, ANOTHER
PROVISION OF THE CARES ACT MAKES
INSURANCE AVAILABLE TO THEM,
TOO.
TYPICALLY UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
IS FOR PEOPLE WITH AN EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONSHIP, EMPLOYEES.
BUT THIS BILL HAS A RELIEF FOR
THEM, TOO.
THERE ARE ALSO SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF PROVISIONS IN THAT ACT
WHICH I THINK ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT.
WHAT THOSE PROVISIONS DO ARE,
THEY SAY TO SMALL BUSINESS, IF
YOU COME IN WE WILL GIVE YOU A
LOAN.
THAT LOAN WILL BE FORGIVABLE IF
YOU KEEP YOUR EMPLOYEES ON
PAYROLL.
THAT’S IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE
IT HELPS KEEP THAT CONNECTION
BETWEEN EMPLOYER AND EMPLOYEE,
BUT IT’S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE
THEIR OWN SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ARE SELF-EMPLOYED.
>> Dana: LET ME ASK YOU THIS
LAST QUESTION.
THIS CAME FROM A VIEWER AS WELL.
IS THERE ANY REASSURING MESSAGE
THAT YOU CAN GIVE TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE
OF COVID-19, AND SOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO APPLY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE, THEY
CAN’T EVEN GET THROUGH BECAUSE
THE PHONE LINES ARE TAKEN UP BY
OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE CALLING?
>> WELL, I THINK THERE’S NO
GETTING AWAY FROM THE FACT THAT
THIS IS A HARD.
FOR MOST AMERICANS.
BUT LET ME EMPHASIZE THESE
THINGS.
FIRST, PART OF WHAT SO JARRING
ABOUT THESE EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
THAT WE SAW TODAY AND YESTERDAY
IS HOW STRONG THE ECONOMY WAS
JUST A MONTH AGO.
WE WERE REPORTING RECORD HIGH IS
A MONTH AGO.
THERE IS IN THAT I THINK BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS AN UNUSUAL
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN AND IT’S NOT
BECAUSE OF THE FUNDAMENTALS OF
THE ECONOMY WERE WEAK, THEY ARE
ACTUALLY VERY STRONG.
THE SECOND THING I WOULD
EMPHASIZE IS DISCIPLINE.
AND I KNOW YOU’VE BEEN TALKING
TO YOUR VIEWERS ABOUT THIS, BUT
DISCIPLINE NOW AND FOLLOWING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURES THAT ARE
BEING URGED WOULD HELP KEEP THIS
SHORT.
SO THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND LET ME SAY FINALLY, JUST AS
THIS CAME ON QUICKLY, WE HAVE A
REAL CHANCE OF ENDING IT QUICKLY
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY HAS BEEN SO
GOOD AND BECAUSE WE HAVEN’T
PLACED THE POLICIES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT MADE THE
ECONOMY STRONG.
IF WE ARE DISCIPLINED AND NOW,
IF EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES TRY
TO KEEP THAT CONNECTION THROUGH
THE LOAN PROGRAM THAT WE
MENTIONED, I THINK WE CAN PULL
OUT OF THIS MORE QUICKLY THAN WE
HAVE ANOTHER ROUGH, ECONOMIC
TIMES.